porque todos
carreteras convertidas en escombros y
carros quemados ese es el resultado del
ataque contra la casa del ministro de
defensa en la noche del martes él y su
familia fueron evacuados con vida pero
varias personas fallecieron y otras
resultaron heridas
el asalto coordinado dejó un daño
generalizado una explosión poderosa
ocurrió cerca de mi tienda y enfrente
del ministerio de defensa de la casa de
mis mil acan fue tan fuerte que incluso
rompió todas las ventanas de las casas
de 500 metros a la redonda y dañó varias
propiedades hasta el polvo apenas se
asentaba en las calles cuando kabul fue
impactada por una segunda explosión el
miércoles como la de tantos otros días
estos últimos ataques ocurren a medida
que los talibanes aumentan la presión
contra el gobierno en medio de la
retirada de las tropas de eeuu el grupo
tomó control de mucha parte del campo y
de varios pueblos y ahora están
apuntando a ciudades como kandahar y
herat
la situación actual es muy mala para los
locales de edad la población lidia con
problemas en todos los frentes las
tiendas están cerradas y todos están
asustados queremos pasa en el padrón de
robots también en el sur la ciudad de
lashkargah también está bajo ataque con
cerca de 200.000 habitantes el ejército
hizo un llamado para que los civiles se
vayan y despejen el camino a una
ofensiva militar los insurgentes dicen
que quieren la paz pero sus acciones
cuentan una historia diferente